If I asked you where gasoline comes from.
It's dinosaurs,
right?
Fossil fuels dug out of the ground,
but it doesn't have to be.
You see,
it's possible to make gasoline synthetically using this,
this and a little bit of energy.
You're gonna have to trust me here.
They're known as E fuels and the people who make believe that they could provide a carbon neutral way to
power combustion engines without having to dig up oil,
giving a second clean life to gas,
guzzling cars,
planes and trains.
But are e fuels really carbon neutral and will we be using them to cleanly power our cars
in the future?
Let's find out.
So the gas that I've just put in my car is made of hydrocarbons,
hydrogen and carbon two elements that are pretty much everywhere.
Carbon is in the CO2 that I'm breathing out and hydrogen is in h2o water.
But how on earth do you turn air and water into gasoline
to answer that?
I've come to synthetic fuel startup zero.
Here,
the company is building a small development line where they say they'll be making 20 liters which is around
five gallons of synthetic fuel.
A day for testing and certification.
Their CEO is this man Paddy Lowe who you may recognize from as many years as technical
director for a string of formula one teams when we burn a hydrocarbon,
we produce carbon dioxide and water and all we do in our chemistry is put those
back together again.
Sounds simple.
Right.
Well,
it's not.
First,
you need to extract hydrogen from water.
Here's X's director,
Professor Nila Shah.
The water is electrolyzing that with an
electric current and it splits the water back into hydrogen and oxygen.
You then need to isolate co two from the air using the carbon capture unit like this one at
Imperial College where Professor Shah teaches.
So now we have carbon dioxide and hydrogen and those form the
starting materials for the next part of our process.
Now zero told me this part is somewhat proprietary,
but essentially the co two and hydrogen are converted using pressure and heat into
h2o and hydrocarbons,
which you can then turn into jet fuel,
diesel and good old fashioned gasoline.
There is no limit because there's no digging anything under the ground.
Everything comes literally from the atmosphere and goes back there when you're finished
with it.
And while that may have been a very simplified explanation of a very complex scientific
process,
it's not exactly a new principle.
After all.
During World war two,
the vast bulk of Germany's aviation fuel and half of its gasoline came from
synthetic fuel.
Manufacturing.
So if it's possible and has been for quite some time,
why aren't e fuels everywhere?
Well,
firstly,
there's the energy required to make them every step of manufacturing,
synthetic fuels can be quite energy intensive and you get a lot less energy out than you
put in.
Our target is for about half the energy that you put in as electricity to end up
as the fuel.
That's led some to question why you would use the fuel for cars when batteries can be more eff
then there's the carbon neutrality for E fuels to be truly carbon neutral.
Their creation has to be powered by sustainable renewable sources like solar
and wind.
And then there's the tailpipe environmental groups point out that while synthetic fuels can create less
emissions than fossil fuels,
they still create more tailpipe emissions than an E V which doesn't have a tail pipe at
all.
Finally,
this cost right now,
this whole process isn't cheap to put it into perspective.
X's limited edition first batch of its fuel,
which is more of a souvenir than anything else runs at just over $200 a gallon.
Though paddy assures me those prices will come down.
We anticipate that we will be making synthetic fuel
at cost parity with fossil fuels within a decade.
So will we be driving synthetic gas guzzlers in the future?
Well,
it depends who you ask see in the eu they've granted an exemption for E fuels in the Bloc's
2035 ban on sales of new internal combustion engines,
which basically means that automakers can continue to sell gas cars providing they only
run on E fuels.
Reporter Bill Boston covers auto and lives in Berlin,
but there are going to be millions of cars on the road for many years to
come that have combustion engines.
They believe that E fuels is a way to keep those cars on the
road and also lower emissions at the same time.
However,
when it comes to investing in E fuels,
if you follow the money,
the amount of investment going into it does not compare in any way what the industry
has already invested in the last 10 years to develop electric vehicles.
So why did the eu throw its weight behind E fuels?
Well,
the reason could have a lot less to do with the environment and a lot more to do with the fact that Germany's
main export is cars.
There are so many jobs that depend on making engines here in
Germany of the around 800,000 jobs
directly related to auto manufacturing.
447,000 of those jobs are linked
specifically to the internal combustion engine.
So what does the future hold for E fuels?
Well,
while it's likely you'll see them powering planes and trains in the years to come.
Their high cost means that it's unlikely you'll see them powering the average family car for quite
some time.